je suis isabelle bouillot je suis la
gérante de la société depil'tech à la
réunion des fils tech est avant tout une
franchise spécialisé dans la photo
d'épilation du travail ont donc la
lumière pulsée nous sommes des photos
thérapeute d'epitech été créé il ya
trois ans dont le siège social est basé
sur nice nous avons ouvert le premier
centre ici à la réunion nous avons
l'exclusivité sur l'océan indien
notre premier centre de lumière pulsée a
donc ouvert ses portes sur saint denis
le général de gaulle nous apportons
réunionnais une solution d'épilation
définitive à travers une technique
efficace mais également maîtrisé à
travers un savoir faire qui est celui de
député des p t c'est une solution
définitive avec un résultat qui est tout
simplement garantie grâce à notre
technique après une formation au sein de
la franchise sur miss la personne qui
prendra le poste chez d'epitech sera
avant tout une technico commercial elle
devra aussi bien procéder à des
traitements en cabine mais également
recevoir la clientèle est là
montée vers des soins les plus adaptées
on va recruter une personne dans le
milieu du service vous allez apporter
aux clientes un service c'est-à-dire
éradiquer ces poils vous allez prendre
en charge la personne l'homme où la
femme en rendez vous d'information lui
donner toutes les informations
concernant notre méthode mais vous allez
ensuite suivre cette personne dans son
évolution laisse lire également dans son
traitement et dans les futurs contrats
qu'elle fera avec vous la fibre
commerciale extrêmement importante mais
également la fibre esthétique est un
plus bonjour je m'appelle retourne à
leslie j'ai 18 ans j'habite à saint
denis
je suis actuellement à la recherche
d'une formation ou d'un stage en
auxiliaires de puériculture j'ai moi
même fait la démarche d'aller en crèche
regarder comment ça se passe et ça m'a
plu donc j'aimerais persister dans ce
domaine sur saint denis ou sur scène
j'ai fait un stage en cabinet de
masseurs kinésithérapeutes et je suis
bénévole pour une association
l'association préparera pour laquelle
j'ai vendu des fleurs pour
les enfants de madagascar je suis
patient social est à l'écouté
j'espère que mon profil vous a plu
j'attends votre appel avec impatience et
je reste à votre disposition pour un
autre utilisé pour monter que j'ai 18
ans j'habite à sa mue
je recherche un contrat en alternance
pour préparer un bac pro commerce de
dinant cette vente en cause du courant
j'ai effectué cette semaine de stage
comme vendeur chez soweto streetwear et
la tripe des stocks 106 me qualité sont
que sutton tu analyses souriant et
surtout motivés viennent travailler en
équipe
contactez moi je suis très très motivé
je voudrais connaître de domaine ce
travail je devais beaucoup beaucoup de
travail et de temps après année poste
que je peux avancer et que je peux
montrer tous tout ce que j'ai je suis
beaucoup beaucoup motivé à prenez moi
bonjour je m'appelle c'est le drame j'ai
26 ans et j'ai le mien me b je cherchais
un secteur d'entreprises entre
saint-andré s'adonner saint denis saint
paul
j'habite à saint denis juste du travail
en peinture bâtiment des plaquistes j'ai
un cap et un bep un bac et un bts et
tout ça en peinture enfin joe black list
j'ai touché ce qui dit revêtements
muraux passagers un terroriste et un
enduit fin et les façades ravalement ce
qu'ils disent et 20 kg en extérieur
depuis vingt les sous-couches à
l'intérieur d'irak grillage c'est les
pros du team hm la finition
j'ai travaillé onze ans en sous
traitance avec gbb et la plus grosse
boîte que j'ai travaillé dans cette
déconfiture
je suis quelqu'un de dynamique je suis
polyvalent et
je prie jeûne heureux je vous ai tout
dit de moi maintenant j'attends comme
beaucoup de filles j'attends que
beaucoup de fils vous prenez moi vous
allez vous verrez pas regretter serez
satisfait de mon travail
j'attends que vos impressions ici
contactez nous sur notre page facebook
www.facebook.com slash 9 7 4 tv ou par
téléphone 02 100 62 92 37 60
de 7 4 cv autre émission au service de
l'emploi à la réunion